the fans of San Antonio know how great
you are and now the whole world does
you are the 2014 Bill Russell MVP
[Applause]
Kawhi Leonard if I had told you in the
NBA Finals began that you would be the
most valuable player of this series you
would have said what
uh man I would have told you he was
lying or something but uh right now it's
just surreal to me I had a great group
of guys behind me just pushing me just
wanted me to do uh to be aggressive in
the game and they just helped me out
now everybody knows the San Antonio
Spurs
the Spurs have a big three
why were you the guy in this finals
oh man I'm not sure I guess I'll just uh
you know they say they have to have the
talent I could go out there every night
and uh they just told me I got to keep
being aggressive every night for us to
win this series uh they all push me
because pop push me the fans pushed me
and I just want to thank God my parents
and everybody
say that again
it's over to me right now well
congratulations Kawhi Leonard is the
youngest Finals MVP since 1999.
it could have been a lot of these guys
but there can only be one MVP and this
year's MVP is a player who didn't start
in a single game until these finals this
year's Bill Russell MVP Andre Iguodala
[Applause]
Andre
the commissioner just mentioned it
758 straight games in your career you
started in what way did your sacrifice
of coming off the bench embody the
spirit of this entire group
um we got a team full of believers we
all go to Chapel before every game we
all believe and we all say God has a a
way for you a purpose for you this is my
purpose and I accepted it and I got
great teammates Steph I want to be just
like Steph when I grow up just a
God-fearing man great guy there's a set
of young eyes on you right here can you
describe what it's like to hold that be
a champion and have your son standing
right here man so much it's my man my
boo boo London at home oh man this is
great we going we're going we're gonna
remember this for a long time
two years ago
he wrote a letter to his fans in which
he said I'm coming home
and he said nothing is given to you in
Northeast Ohio
everything is earned and LeBron it was
unanimous Most Valuable Player 2016 NBA
Finals congratulations
[Applause]
thank you
LeBron in that letter that Adam Silver
referenced you said the most important
thing to you was to bring a championship
to Northeast Ohio why was that so
important
um I understood what the people of
Northeast Ohio been through the last 50
plus years
I kept it
I kept it at Bay I never stressed the
fact that I didn't feel the pressure
that none of those things so it always
kept me level-headed but I understood
what everyone in Northeast Ohio been
through the last 50 plus years and I'm
happy to be a part of History I can't
wait to get back home I'm ready to get
to you guys
what kind of character did it require of
a group that had so many playing in
their first NBA finals
to come out and win on this floor we've
been through so much adversity these
last two years
I just knew who was capable of even
being down 3-1
versus greatest regular season team ever
you know 73-9 and everybody counted us
out and that's when we strive the most
when everybody count us out and that's
definitely when I strive the most when
everybody count me out look run the one
two titles in Miami and I know they
meant the world to you why does this one
feel different
[Applause]
I'm home
this is what I came back for
uh I'm at a loss for words uh this is
unbelievable it doesn't feel real right
now congratulations thank you Doris
thank you so much
in his 10th year in the league
he's been a perennial All-Star
he's been a league MVP but he's never
been the finals MVP
you're Bill Russell 2017 Finals MVP
Kevin Durant
[Applause]
thank you
Kevin your basketball resume when you
arrived here already read multi-time
scoring champion NBA MVP but now it will
read NBA champion and finals MVP why are
those things important to you it's a
team sport you know and you want to
achieve the highest honor in the team
sport which is winning the championship
on the door with these guys is amazing
in front of these fans man
you guys were great tonight we needed it
the chance now I appreciate it
you took your share of criticism but you
said win or lose you had made the right
decision what have you found with this
particular group of guys here in Golden
State
well is this a great group of guys great
Community great Arena great fans
[Applause]
part of it man I can't wait to celebrate
my teammates in the locker room
you talk about your mom and the
influence she said we'll give you one
final opportunity to maybe express some
sentiments to her here
thank you
we did it
I told you when I was eight years old we
did it yeah
congratulations Bill thank you for being
here to help me present the Bill Russell
MVP trophy
and this year the back-to-back NBA
Finals MVP Kevin Durant
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Kevin
only six times in history as a Player
gone back to back MVP and I know you
take such incredible pride in your craft
and the work you put into this
but how much of this is about more than
just the winning and the titles and
these individual accolades for you oh
this is about the journey you know all
season man getting up every day going to
work with these guys is you know it was
amazing the environment is is incredible
it's good for you to be around guys like
this it helps you become a better
basketball player and a better man and
it's a journey that's better than a
destination you know I'm happy I'm a
part of this group you have had to go
through a man you have professed
incredible respect for and has been a
great champion in his own right LeBron
James so can you give us some sense of
two great players going at it head to
head in this particular kind of
environment oh it's fun it's fun as uh
you know the competition
um you when you play against one of the
best it brings the best idea as well it
brought the best out of our team and I'm
just grateful we got back-to-back
championships and looking forward to
going celebrating the locker room right
now actually let's go to it thank you
Kevin
but of course here with Bill Russell on
the 50th anniversary of your 11th and
final championship thank you for being
here and our MVP following an iconic
buzzer beater and a dominant performance
in the finals
your 2019 Bill Russell Finals MVP is
Kawhi Leonard
foreign
congratulations
[Applause]
so I throughout the course of this
series you touched on the fact that a
year ago you were not playing basketball
and you had to make your way to a new
city with new teammates but one thing
that never seemed to waver was your
Poise and your confidence what gives you
that Steely resolve
oh man just uh
Life Experiences
my teammates they did a great job of you
know walking me with open arms
the management
so they just told me to come out and
play basketball man you know I'm a guy
that just you know try to not get too
high or too low
and um yeah it worked out it worked out
you you make it very clear that you are
about winning and not records nor
anything else but tonight
by by winning your second MVP of the
finals with a different team you join
select company Kareem and LeBron James
as you let that sink in what crosses
your mind
man uh
last summer man
uh was going through a lot
was going through a lot
and
you know I had a great support system
I just kept working hard working hard
and had My Mind Set On This goal right
here I came to a team
a new coach that mindset was the same as
mine trying to get trying to get that
Larry OB over there
and you know this is what I play
basketball for this is what I work out
for all summer during the season and I'm
happy that my hard work paid off I know
you're gonna celebrate this but I know
Jurassic Park 37 million people the men
behind you you have such an important
decision how does a championship shape
what you have in front of you
I'm about to enjoy this with my
teammates and coaches and I'll think
about that later yes you should
congratulations
and I have a feeling that this Finals
MVP is going to have a trophy named
after him one day the finals MVP is
LeBron James
oh my god oh you're stuck with him
LeBron congratulations
you said the other day and I want to
read this to get it exactly right Lakers
fans quote don't give a damn about what
you've done before when you become a
Laker you've got to do it with them as
well well you have done it LeBron what
does it mean to you
um means a lot
it means a lot to represent this
franchise
um
Genie I told Jeannie when I came here
that uh I was gonna put this franchise
back in a position where it belongs
her late great father did it for so many
years and she just you know took it on
after that and for me to be a part of
such a historical franchise is uh it's
an unbelievable feeling not only for
myself but for my teammates for the
organization for the coaches for the
trainers everybody that's here
um
we just want our respect Rob wants his
respect coach Vogel want his respect our
organization what they respect Laker
Nation want their respect
and I want my damn respect too
[Applause]
four finals MVPs your fourth title with
three franchises
[Applause]
extremely Elite company and in year 17
as well
you got a guy in your ear right now
telling you're the greatest of all time
you're just a couple months shy of your
36th birthday
is this the longest crime in the history
of professional sports I don't know I'm
gonna let you guys talk about it one
thing I can do is uh commit to the game
I put myself and my body and my mind in
position to be available to my teammates
um I've never missed the playoff game in
my career and uh the best thing you can
do for your teammates is be available
and uh for me to be available to my
teammates and put in the work
um I just hope I make my guys proud and
that's all that matter to me I made my
guys proud make the fan base crowd my
family back home I can't wait to get
back home to them
Akron Ohio we did it again and um you
know that's what it's all about
[Applause]
I've had to work together to get this
trophy here tonight
I mean it's easy
it's easy I set it in the pressure
before we have no ego
um we want the best from each other
every single day both in off the floor
on and off the floor and I know what it
means to have seven years uh when you
feel like
um that you can't get over the hump you
know I had seven years my first then in
Cleveland I felt like I couldn't get
over the hump I felt like I needed some
help I feel like I need someone to push
me and that's when I was able to go to
Miami and get pushed by D Wade and Bosch
in that franchise and so to be able to
get him and we push him and let him know
how great he is but just making them see
better basketball and better to be a
part of something that's special
that's what it's all about so to be able
to put him where he is today that means
so much to me and the fact that he
trusts me uh means even more
you were very vocal coming in here that
you weren't just trying to win a title
in this bubble but you wanted to be a
real voice for social change and what
has been one of the most turbulent years
in American history when you look back
about what the entire NBA Brotherhood
did in this bubble what will you think
of it's been unbelievable has been
unbelievable we didn't know it was an
unknown
um but I think Adam I think everybody
from the NBA to mbpa putting this thing
together
um you know and US using our voices
using being together you know you hear
Golden State always use the phrase
strengthen numbers and that's exactly
what it was while we were here as a as
the NBA as the mbpa all our players
everybody had a voice on what's going on
in America so um we know we want to we
all want to see better days and when we
leave here we got to continue to push
that continue to push social injustice
continue to push for voter suppression
continue to push for police brutality
continue to push for everything that's
the opposite of love and I think if we
could continue to do that all of us um
America would be a much better place
which we all love this this country
LeBron thank you so much for pushing
against all of those things
congratulations thank you on that trophy
in your history appreciate it I don't
think there's much doubt but he played
through adversity he played through
injury
no doubt given he was the two-time MVP
in the league this year's Bill Russell
Finals MVP Janice
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
be honest
when you re-signed here you said that
you wanted to be a part of building a
championship culture in Milwaukee for
years to come what does it mean to you
to make good on that commitment in the
city that drafted you
means a lot I want to thank Milwaukee
for believing in me
you know I think my teammates man they
played hard everything every freaking
game you know I trusted this team I
wanted to do it here in the city I
wanted to do with this guy so I'm happy
I'm happy that we're able to get it done
it
[Applause]
it is a rarity honest to be able to play
eight years with the teammate let alone
win a championship together in those
eight years how would you describe what
Chris Middleton means to you Chris
you did it huh you [__] did it
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I'm happy I'm happy man
this guy this guy doesn't really know
how much he pushed me he pushed me every
day to be great he pushes me every every
day to be great man and I'm happy that I
can step on the floor with this guy and
play every single movie these guys and
the rest of the guys but please
especially we've been together for eight
years and I'm happy that I was able to
do it with him I'm happy that I was able
to do this team from Milwaukee and how
Coach bat say we got to do it again
[Applause]
shy
that family is at the core of everything
you do and now you and two of your
brothers are NBA champions
hey I'm just
I'm just happy I'm happy that you know a
lot of people is making uh jokes last
year when closest one is a championship
with the Lakers and you know obviously
uh and the dinner table was awkward a
little bit because he had the ring
before me but now me at the nice
happening so so we're happy we [__]
happy
to be honest congratulations
Chris Middleton bring it up now let's
bring back Deputy Commissioner Mark
Tatum
to present the 2022 Bill Russell NBA
Finals Most Valuable Player award
Thank you Lisa
he's a four-time NBA champion
a two-time league MVP a member of our
75th Anniversary team and for the first
time ever he's in NBA Finals MVP the
2022 Bill Russell NBA Finals MVP award
goes to Stephen Curry
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
ly get this finals MVP
it means we won it means we took
advantage of the opportunity getting
back here and
I mean I hear all the conversations I
hear all the chatter we hear all the
chatter
and then in the day it's about what we
do on the floor
ain't got to talk about it just gotta go
do it and that's what this is about
you said it during our post-game
interview just three seasons ago you
guys had the worst record in the league
at what point did you believe that you
could be back up here you always had a
doubt but
you know how long the road is to uh to
get back here because of how hard it is
to win on this level Boston is a great
team everything we played in the west is
a great teams but we found a way to just
get it done and uh everybody on the
stage had a partners from the front
office coaches players
at the beginning of the year what were
they saying we weren't even on the radar
and now we're here with two trophies and
it means a lot I mean every Championship
journey is different how would you
describe how would you describe this one
yeah combining our Championship pedigree
and our experience with some fresh
energy some guys that are really hungry
to take their next step
but we've built this for 10 11 years
and that means a whole lot when you get
to the stage because you know how to win
and everybody who's been a part of this
knows what it's about so this is uh this
one is different this one is different
for sure congratulations to you Steph
where's clay
this is the first
Finals MVP trophy that we're giving out
since Bill Russell's passing
and he'd be incredibly pleased it's
another Center
Bill Russell finals in
Nicola jokic
[Applause]
thank you
Nicola you've said that you never
envisioned any of this for yourself
being an All-Star two-time MVP and now a
Finals MVP but what does it mean to you
to now just Just To Be A Champion to be
able to celebrate with their family you
know Adrian said really one really good
thing we are we are not winning for
ourselves we have anything for the for
the the guy next to us and that's why
this more is even more because uh I was
waiting for Jamal tomorrow
and uh this is a great group of people a
great group of teammates uh like I said
in uh from the from the family crunchy
to the Sparky engine
everything everything this this year was
amazing what are you most proud of about
this team you know we believe in each
other the relationship that we had uh
yes trophies in something but I think we
had some relationship but it's going to
be uh long long like even even after me
finished careers thank you Nicola
congratulations